hey guys this is andrew for
childrenscences.com so for those who are
watching my video for the first time
let me quickly introduce myself i've
been working as a professional trader
uh actually an option trader for the
past six years in hong kong
and i've decided a few months ago guys
to do some youtube videos
because i want to pass the knowledge i
want to show you guys all the different
tools and techniques
that i use at work to make money on the
markets and i want to show you guys
how to use it yourself so if you want to
know about all this stuff
you guys are in the right place so today
i want to make an update on
amc let's get into it
[Music]
so this is the amc chart on a daily time
frame so i do like regular updates
and i need to say that nothing is
happening you know there is not that
much activity you know the volumes
look at the volumes they're just going
lower by the way i just spot something
guys
but you can do a trendline on the volume
you know and same thing guys when we
break it they're going to be more volume
so maybe it's going to be around the
eighths of april something like this but
this is just you know a very rough guess
but
i i don't expect much to happen for the
coming weeks i mean in terms of like
strong moves
let me show you very quickly you know
the kind of longer term analysis because
i think
we have some time here you know maybe
one week at least maybe like one month
before things start to kick in
let me show you guys some basic
trendline stuff
that is giving you some nice support
levels so when i connect you know the
two recent highs that i have
on those different trends i've done this
before but i'm just doing
it quickly here again so you can see
that here we have the first breakout so
i connect
this one and this one in this trend we
have the first breakout here then we
retest it a bit messy then we go higher
and we go to the next one and the next
one guys is like when i connect this one
and this one
and you can see here that we do the
breakout perfectly
we are retesting it and look guys here
what is happening
it has actually hold guys so we went to
nine
but only one day for a trend line to be
broken you need to have two consecutive
days that close below
and the next day right after guys we
went above and we closed at 11
and right now guys we're consolidating
here so this is what i'm
expecting for the coming week i don't
expect any strong moves
up at the moment like i said in my
previous videos what can happen as well
is that you know corrective moves of
often
developed in three ways so maybe you
know we're gonna have some kind of
a b c stuff you know something like this
maybe
worst case 750 i told you guys this but
like you know this trend line is gonna
act as support
so i think we're gonna have some kind of
consolidation here you know until the
15th of april something like this
and then of course guys we're gonna keep
moving higher all right
my levels are here i showed you guys
already this but let me show you again
i just measured the first way that i
applied to the bottom of the second wave
and i have my fib extensions
and the most likely one is the 1.618 35
which surprisingly is as well the
maximum dual time high we got on amc
so when you have this kind of double
information coming from two different
methods
it gives more weight to your scenario so
35 is
my level and i'm very convinced we're
gonna go there but not
right away guys all right so let me show
you something else i'm going to show you
some information about
option chain so you go on yahoo finance
you tap amc
you go to options just here and you
select your different expiry so once
again
the 16th of april is very liquid but on
amc guys you need to go to juno the
information is on the 18th of june and
you can see that on the 18th of june you
have a
very big amount of call options on the
four for the strike
so i computed this data the same i did
for gamestop and
here is the results so this is only for
april and if i convert it into national
go check my other videos to see how i do
it
uh the notion that is sitting at the 40
strike is around
160 million us dollar so guys it's not
that big all right as a percentage of
market cap is only one percent
so you can have this kind of gamma
squeeze as well on amc
but this needs to grow so i'm gonna
follow this for now it's not that big
and you can see guys that for gamestop
you have a very high concentration of
coal options
on the april maturity 16th of april so
you know a big move is expected very
soon
on amc you don't have anything on april
this is april guys all right this is
the open interest but the shape is the
same you don't have you have
zero open interest at the 40 strike you
don't have anything at the 30 so people
don't believe
amc can go to you know you have the 20
strike all right
but above 25 nobody believes it for may
it's same and need to wait for june
to see the option of an interest to kick
in
and in june you have this kind of stuff
guys all right you have this 38
000 shares that are here which if i
convert international gives me 200
million national
so this is what can create a gamma
squeeze but we need more of this we
don't see it
now let me quickly go have a look at the
short interest the short interest of amc
yes same i complete the data
for the every two weeks and i record it
here it went from 40
to 10 so hedge funds are actually
offloading their positions they're
actually
buyers guys same as as for game stop you
know so there won't be a problem
you know they won't put any selling
pressure because you can see that
they're basically you know just
offloading the short positions probably
because they're not allowed anymore to
you know have some short positions for
those
hot stocks and so nmc is just going to
follow a normal development
of this kind of stock that corrects the
lot and it's probably going to come back
to its all-time high
step by step so i don't know june is a
nice target i think that maybe
in june we're going to be at 35 in the
coming month
i see much more activity happening on
gamestop only if i look at the
option open interest which is what i do
every day
so guys if you enjoyed this video please
don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button and of course
you're gonna be the first to know when i
upload anything
new about amc gamestop or other
stock that is hot and stay close to show